[Music]
my talk will be
around data lineage with apache airflow
using marquez so we're
we're going to outline a lot of the work
that we've done integrating marquez with
airflow uh
talk about some of the challenges that
we we've seen along the way and also
talk
you know briefly about the marquez api
and then dive into
the integration so
yeah briefly about me yeah i'm a really
i used to
work at wework i was working on the
marquez project there
and now i'm working as a software
engineer at datakin which is a
commercial offering
of mark marquez um and it's also a
startup around data up so really
understanding
once you once your data scientist or
analyst
analyst writes some sql they're like hey
these are the business metrics that we
care about
and we want to now schedule a workflow
or a pipeline that runs and feeds
feeds our metrics of business metrics on
a periodic basis
really understanding once you hand that
sql over to a data engineer and they
have to write a pipeline
with airflow or some other scheduler uh
really what happens there so a lot of a
lot of context is missed um
there's there's very little
understanding or visibility and when
that pipeline does run
and the data is incorrect uh how do you
track those how do you track those
issues
so that's that's going that's really
what the what the startup's about and
it's a pretty
exciting field uh to be in uh you can
reach me on twitter so it's just ws
luke chuke um and uh briefly now just
in terms of the what will what this talk
will be about we're going to ask the
question why metadata so brief
introduction on
what the problems we're trying to solve
with metadata
we'll go into an intro marquez and then
dive into the marquez and air flow
integration and then
we'll talk about the future work so
really what are what are some features
that we're building
at datakin but also in the open source
community and things to be excited for
so in today's world as a data engineer
you have limited context so what what
you when you
begin to write a pipeline a lot of the
questions that you do ask yourself is
one where is the data source located so
am i connecting to postgres um
my sequel is this not even a database am
i connected to a distributed file system
what is the schema so what is the
contract so i i need to know what is
and what are the fields uh is this a
file if it's a file is it an avro
so those are type of questions that you
ask yourself
who is the owner really is there a clear
owner that i could reach out to
most likely a team that owns the data
the dataset lifecycle
and also how often is the is the data
data updated and
this is this deals with data freshness
there's this hourly weekly
um where the or the data set is is
updated
uh where is the data coming from um and
also who is who's using this data so
mainly if if i'm if i'm pulling in a
data set as
part of my pipeline am i the only user
um are there other
are there other teams that might be
building the same pipeline
that are answering this the same type of
questions
so really what we're missing is the
context and really data is not just
a box uh there's there's sources like
like i mentioned where
you have my sql postgres um warehouses
uh streaming data sets
and um like kafka and also distributed
file systems like like s3
and then there's there's different type
of formats so there's csv json some that
are
schema-less but some that have a tight
contract like avro
um and some that are more columnar so
more efficient for for reading
like like parquet
all right so let's ask ourselves why why
metadata why are
a lot of companies investing in metadata
collection
um i think we can narrow it down to
three three
three concepts one is data quality so
really if
i am going to read a data set do i do i
know the owners of
a lot of the questions that we were
asking ourselves before it's not just a
box
that says data i need to know are there
are there fields that should not be no
are there fields that should be within a
range
specifically if i'm reading from a table
i need to
need to understand if the quality drops
for for some
for for some reason am i
am i able to identify that quickly
specifically this is
pretty important for financial reports
um really if you're
crunching data and you're now seeing
you're producing these financial reports
that
trickle up to the ceo um are we are we
are we making sure that those um those
data points that we're we're
ingesting in our pipeline and consuming
are correct
um the other the other thing becomes
once you have the data quality
down and there's a lot of tools out
there that do this one
in particular is great expectations um
so if you haven't checked out that tool
i'd recommend it
and it's pretty exciting uh project the
the other one is okay so once you
understand the data quality
um what about understanding the
dependencies so you could have an
immediate dependent
uh you could have a team that produces a
dsf for you
but that they also have probably three
or four
different levels above them where they
consume their data
so really understanding if something if
my pipeline is failing
can i understand and follow the uh the
the path upstream to understand is the
data
uh corrupt or is it actually my pipeline
and the code that i
i push out recently uh causing problems
and at the same time
understanding who consumes your data so
downstream dependencies
will also be affected by your pipeline
failing or recent release that
introduced a bug
and once you have data quality and data
lineage um then you have democratization
so
those data lines gives you the ability
to then uh
allow users to be more self-sufficient
and debug their own problems
um and also the whole data discovery
aspect so uh
being able to say okay i want to write a
pipeline that
in this case for for wework a lot of my
examples will be around that
if i want to know how many um like an
important data set is
you know how often uh do we see turn
month to month if
people are not renewing their membership
uh you should be able to answer that
yourself and be able to
discover the most the top data sets of
your company
all right so the next what we'll talk
about um we'll give you an intro to
marquez the you know when we started the
project at wework
now just um about almost two years ago
the
we it was a whiteboard session we talked
about the data model and then shortly
after we
we uncovered this ground paper that was
published by berkeley
um in 2017 and it's a really really
great foundation so if you
if you're interested in the metaspace
and you want to understand you know the
importance of metadata
uh versioning your your code but also
the the
the data sets themselves and
understanding the lifecycle this is an
amazing paper that
you know i'd recommend people read to to
get the
the strong foundation you need to better
understand why why companies are
investing
in metadata
so if we look at the the three concepts
so data lineage understanding
your upstream and downstream
dependencies data discovery
you know being able to as an employee of
a company searching for
the most important and critical data
sets that you need to
write your pipelines or produce reports
and then data governance
that's mostly around tagging your data
sets as having pii
especially with gdpr being a big thing
and if you look at the intersection of
these three
concepts you see marquez marquez
supports the data limited side
does those provide the search capability
but at the same time
does allow you to tag fields and data
sets
so at the core marquez is a it's a
really simple service just to collect
metadata around your sources data sets
and jobs and there's apis for each one
um which we'll go to go into in later
slides so you'll you'll be able to
register your sources and then from
there you'll be able to register your
data sets
as and then from there because there's a
certain flow that will go
into uh then it allows you to register
your jobs and that's the the job api is
what allows us to build out
the lineage with the with the diagram on
the right you'll see that you
you know you could use the rest api um
so we have clients for python
and java to send metadata to marquez um
so if you have etl jobs if you have
batch jobs
or like spark and then also streaming so
we've done some work
on integration with with streaming data
sets uh that all gets populated
in the uh marquez of meta metastore
and what that allows you to do you have
a data governance of like i mentioned
before
you can tag data sets uh as having pii
or if it's sensitive
um and with the ability with data
lineage you could then say okay if
one job is consuming a data set and that
data says tagged as having
sensitive information or as pii you can
then track downstream
it's most likely that those jobs or
those data sets that were produced
by uh those data sets are con those jobs
are consuming
that data set uh they most likely will
have pii
um at least you'll be able to to ask the
team
um or look at the sql that's being
executed the other component is just
data discovery and this is just a simple
okay give me a list of the jobs and
lists of the data sets
and the way the way the the the service
or
is um is broken down is you have the
apis and libraries and
the one thing um that this that we'll go
into is the integration that we've done
with airflow
but we're also looking into integrating
with with spark as well
and the the api is broken down to three
separate services
so you have your core um
core service which is responsible for
capturing job data set and source
metadata but also
the versioning on the back end um and
then that that's stored and so if you
look at the
the bottom where you look at the storage
that's stored in a postgres
database currently um so as we collect
job and dataset metadata we then
replicate or send that data over to a
graph database which then exposes the
lineage
lineage capability and tracks the inputs
and outputs for
for each job and then on top of that you
just have a light search
search capability and we're just right
now we're testing out
elasticsearch to to index some of our
smart jobs and data sets
so the at a high level the the core the
core data model has
jobs data sets and sources but the
versioning capabilities and the one of
the more interesting things that we
built out
so for every job run you do have data
set versions
so job will have more uh more than one
for
or one-to-many a job version that really
happens when you change your inputs and
outputs
but also the code um so we link with
link called job
runs to code and for every job run that
you have which is just an instance of a
job version
you then have different data sets that
it consumes and produce and we link
the data set versions to the input of
the run and every run
modifies a data set and produces a new
data set version
with data sets they are linked to one or
more sources
so we we have mysql postgres redshift
and so forth
there's different types of data sets so
we have a very generic model that allows
us to capture metadata
for different different type of sources
and more at a high level you have
versioning for
db tables and that's one you know
depending on the type of source we
version
based off the columns so for db tables
we look at the fields
what call i'm sorry what columns have
changed what are their types
for file systems that's a little bit
different we're looking at
apache iceberg which an exciting project
that came out of netflix that allows you
to
uh to version distributed file systems
and then for streaming capabilities
that's a little bit more challenging
um i think the i mean the approach that
we're taking now is if you're
the schema for a stream changes that
becomes a new version but there's a lot
of work to still
still to do in in that area
so what are some of the design benefits
of this i mean one of them
by far as debugging so being able to
understand what job version produce what
data subversions means
you'll be able to know what downstream
jobs will have been affected by this
corrupt data
uh so if you're just if you're updating
uh
tables and you were you modified the
version of a data set
of the version of the column i'm sorry
the the type of the column
before you do that you can actually
check okay what are the what are the
jobs that could be affected by this
chain so really
uh it comes down to i have a contract so
my job
produces a data set and that contract is
the data set itself and how are how are
my
uh how are other teams going to interact
with my data set and that's usually
it comes down to the schema one example
that you see a lot is
you as a data engineer you you release
new versions of your pipeline or
quite a bit so you update your code um
and really
a lot oftentimes you don't see the issue
until about you know
two weeks later and that's when you
start seeing discrepancies in your
dashboards you're like okay what's going
on
so really figuring out where the problem
um
started or where was it introduces is a
very difficult thing to solve
so what for for what we're trying to do
is being able to say okay this was
the job version that produced that data
set and these are all the jobs
um that use that data set version um and
that that helps
out with backfilling so really we're
trying to make backfilling not a
difficult pro
you know more of a simpler thing to to
try to address
because right now when you do want to do
a backfill there's a lot of people that
you have to or a lot of teams that you
have to
interact with to see who was affected by
this corrupt data or this this address
that we had
all right so how is metadata collected
in marquez
um one is push based currently we just
make api calls
to the so the job itself has the
integration and we then send the
metadata
job and data metadata to marquez via its
rest api
and right now we have two uh two sdks
one is java
and the other one is python
so what i want to do is walk you through
quickly the different steps that we
the or the flow that you have to take in
order to begin to register metadata
so here the first thing we're going to
do is register the source i think that's
really important is like first
how do i how do i connect to the
database or how do i access
the data set itself so here we're going
to have we're going to register postgres
source we're going to give the name
analyticsdb
and we're going to provide the
connection url really just to understand
how do we connect to this source and
then provide a description
next we're going to register a data set
uh the dataset metadata that's
associated with
that source so here we're going to give
a we're going to find a type db table
we're going to give a name we're going
to name the data set room bookings
we're going to give it a physical name
called public.roombookings
and i do want to pause you briefly this
is really important um
you do have a sumarcus has a concept of
logical data sets and physical data sets
so logical data sets are independent of
the type where it's stored
um you know think things of things like
that also
it doesn't really care about partitions
and the physical name is really
bound to the physical source of where
your data set is so here
in postgres you're going to have public
dot room bookings so you have the
schema.table name
but you could give you know you could
give the data set whatever name you like
that's more that's more the name that
marquez knows while the physical name is
more
what the source knows
we give the source name and so just
continue you give the source name
analytics tb
you give it a name space and here we
just have data science so here
this is how we track ownership in
marquez so you you'd be able to say
these are all the data sets that are
associated with data science so you do
have a logical grouping of your metadata
and the naming convention is
so you have uniqueness within a
namespace but not across native spaces
so namespace is just really
our way of applying ownership to
metadata you provide the fields here
it's just
name type description and also tags if
you
if you do want to provide them and pro
and also then give a description
so what so once you have your sources
and once you have your data sets then
you can
begin registering your job and here we
just have a batch job that's
that's going to send in emails
for room bookings in the past seven days
as
inputs you give the name space that the
room booking is associated with
here it doesn't produce any outputs
because we're going to send an email
and the the versioning so the the
pointer to code is the location so here
we have
a pointer to github um that references a
particular
uh git shot then we bound our name space
and we then
provide the description
so just linking kind of linking what we
discussed you have your
your analytics db which is linked to the
data set source
and then you have your data set which is
then linked to your job and those use
logical names
so this allows you to build uh data
abstraction so not really your job
really doesn't care
that your data set could be in multiple
sources
have multiple partitions it just knows
that the name and then behind the scenes
the source can change
and yeah the ownership here is just the
data science data science team
that's uh yeah that's just a name space
you have there
all right so now now briefly we're going
to walk through the versioning
component as well so and really how we
build a lineage graph
so here initially we had for our room
booking seven days job
we have just one output i'm sorry one
input which is called room booking
and behind the scenes we have a here the
circles represent a job and
the squares represents the data set so
that's your input
and here it has no outputs but what
happens a lot is you
it's not your job doesn't remain static
your inputs and outputs don't remain
static
so once you provide an output uh the
version of the job changes and the
marquez back in
but then at the same time the lineage
graph then creates a
an edge from your job node to the room
booking aggregates so here we have an
we're not just sending emails but we're
also aggregating
room bookings which you kind of see a
lot whether
you have it by day which is often
often the case or by week
okay so now with the the foundation of
really how
we collect metadata let's go let's go
into
the airflow the airflow integration
so the airflow support that we have for
marquez um really
really is a library that uh really cuts
across the different tags so you
um we'll go into how the integration
works and how you add the
the library to your airflow tag but you
could have multiple dags that are
running
and they all leverage the marquez
library
for airflow and the just for some
background i know a lot of people
know airflow and it's really a common
common scheduler that
a lot of companies use but for you know
at a high level they
you have your dags which represent a
direct acyclic graph
and each dag consists of multiple tasks
and that's really where
all the work is done so airflow has a
number of operators like postgres
and a number of others that you can use
and pull and pull into
your your dag and i'll actually produce
you know actually make things a lot
easier to connect to postgres and
run your sql so it's really uh you know
it makes it very easy
to to use these abstractions to build
out build out your pipeline
so the metadata that we collect for
a dag is the task life cycle so when a
dag starts
it kicks off your task so for every task
we collect the run metadata
i'm sorry the run state so initially we
we look at the the sql we look at
the sources that you're connecting with
and then we create a run for
for that task and that's just metadata
around the run itself so if you're
passing in
default arguments to your to your dag we
also we also capture that as well and
tie that to the run
so we look at the entire life cycle of
the task
like i mentioned we collect the
parameters so if you have if you're
sending an email to someone if your
pipeline fails
that's going to be part of the run
metadata that marquez clocks on the back
end
we then look at the and this is the
important part when your task runs
um it's usually because you've you've
updated well
first you have to uh define your dag and
then depending on how
you're syncing in the code uh or the new
dags that are
that are created for your your airflow
instance it's got to go out to github
so there's a git sync that we leverage
and um we create the
the github link to the git shop
then we we provide that github link that
we produced and added to the locations
field that i
i showed earlier which allows us to then
know which what was the code that ran
for that task
and then form the sql parsing we then do
the inputs and outputs um
well that's how we define the inputs and
outputs we look at if
a lot of a lot of what we focus on is
sql based so we will go and see the the
sql parsing
uh in later slides but we look at what
are
and it it's fairly simple i mean we look
at what tables
you're reading from and also what table
you're writing to
and this is a a really nice thing
because right now with um with airflow
you have
an understanding of the dags and the
tasks but not really what
the what the inputs and outputs are are
for each tag
so what you do is you get a level above
the dag itself so now we
remove the tasks above the dag and now
you have a complete
intra inter dag dependency graph for
all the tags that are running within
your airflow instance
so the it also comes with a built-in sql
parser so like i mentioned earlier we
when you run when you run it or use a
postgres operator
um we look at the the sql field and we
look at the sql that's being executed
we parse that and register that job
metadata
it comes with a link linked to code
builder right now we just have github
but you can imagine gitlab
is another thing that we support and
then there's this concept of meta
metadata extractors so
i'll go into that briefly but the idea
is you for every operator
that you have there's also a an
extractor that's shipped along with the
library
that is really um it really just
inspects the operator and looks to see
does it have an extractor that matches
that and if it does let me
let me pull the metadata from that
operator before the text
the the task executes
so at a very high level view if you
integrate the library the dag runs
it uses the marquez integration and it
sends all this information to marquez
back in and
and populates the data model that we we
talked about uh so the source
that you're connecting to the the
different data sets that
are part of the part of your sql and
then as well as the job
and using the the github builder link we
can then say okay this was the version
of your code for this task when it
executed
and then as well as all the run metadata
that's associated with uh with your task
so the the market therefore library is
open sourced um
and that was something we we spent a
good amount of time
internally at wework and then eventually
eventually open sourced
like i mentioned it enables global task
level metadata collection
uh so not just having the view of the
dag
itself and just the tasks you could you
could dive in a bit deeper and
understand what are the inputs and
outputs for the dag itself
and it doesn't so the the the airflow
integration that we have it doesn't
modify the class at all it just extends
it
and what i mean by that is it wraps the
dag class
and allows you um to continue to use
the dag class as if it was just the
uh sort of the core part of the the
airflow library
but before the task before the dag runs
we extract metadata
and then report that metadata to marquez
and then
allow the dac to execute so to change
from
so it's imported so here for our room
booking 7 day dag
we go from from a airflow import dag to
from marquez underscore import tag
so the idea is that you have operators
extractors
and eventually the metadata that's
extracted from from the operator
so with airflow you have a number of
vanilla a number of vanilla operators
in this example i'll talk about postgres
and with the marquez library you have a
mapping
of different operators to different
extractors
and that's where we we can see a lot of
if someone wants to contribute to the
library
and be part of the marquez community you
can contribute a lot of these different
extractors
that pull in pull in the metadata for
the for the operator itself
so if we look at the type of metadata
that's extracted um so here i have a
really
really simple new runebooking dag which
generates
inserts into uh into room bookings so
the the one thing that
you have to define is your postgres
connection id and that's your analytics
cv
and that maps to the source so the
source that we talked about that's a
prereq
in order to start sending metadata to
marquez we we define the source
so we know what database we're
connecting to
and then we we have to do we have to
then uh register the data set so as
as the operator or as the marquez
library extractor is looking at this
operator
it's looking at all these different
fields so the one thing that we're
looking at is the the sql field uh so
we're in this case it's just tokenizing
it
um we're not we're not writing our own
um there's a
i forgot the library that we're using to
uh to parse this out but
it just we just get a set of tokens so
we get insert into
values and we look at what table we're
inserting to
and then that becomes the room booking
and in this case we've identified
that it's a room bookings table so that
becomes a data set that we register
along with our with our job metadata
and then finally the what we end up
doing is the task id becomes
uh the job name there's a number of ways
you can you could name the job
uh you could pre you could add a prefix
of the maybe the dag name uh maybe the
cluster i'm sorry the airflow instance
if you have multiple
uh airflow instances running
uh you might be able to you might be
able to come up with a different naming
convention to do that but
you know that's something we're playing
around with namespaces
give you a long get you pretty far if
you want to do a multi-tenancy
um approach to to your airflow instances
if you're doing that
but for for our purposes and for this
example we're just using the task id
as um as the room as the job name which
is just
new room bookings
so the the what what what does this give
you so
if you have all these different tasks
that report this metadata
to the marquez backend you don't just
have a view of
one dag for new room bookings and one
dag for top
run booking is dags i'm sorry
top for the you have a dag that computes
the top room bookings for
um an office space
so in the in the middle they're actually
connecting to the
room bookings table which gives you the
location
of the of the room uh sort of is this in
san francisco
is this in new york uh what time what
time the
room booking happened and also what was
um you know how often was that room
was that room booked uh so
what so with the with the you know what
we what we saw a lot at wework was
you know you had all these different
jobs that were um really running complex
sequels and
not really understanding which which
tags depended on one another and
with the with the ability to just
inspect the dag uh inspect the dax tas
and parse the sequel
and register that to the marquez back
and you'd be able to build
this lineage graph that's not dependent
on
the airflow instance or if you're
running multiple airflow instances
you're not just tied
to the view of that airflow instance you
can see across
cross-air flow deployments and the
dependencies between them
so some of the future work so next we'll
talk about
some of the future work that we're we're
doing with the with the marquez project
at datakin
the the the short-term roadmap is the
one thing that we did see a lot in the
community that
is requested and this is just a side
effect of what we you know as we were
developing
at wework we had a particular stack with
snowflake
redshift and we were using dbt and kafka
but we made those sources and we didn't
make those sources configurable so
really saying
if i have a new source i want to be able
to say these are the
these are the field types that are
supported so for for instance
with with postgres and mysql you know
some of the field
some of the column types are integers
some of them can be strings
but there might be types that aren't
supported so we want to make sure that
you if you have a new source that you
want to collect metadata for we want to
make that really easy
and that's something we're working
towards um internally
at datacam we're also focusing uh a lot
on the airflow integration and
really to expand the support for the
airflow operators um
i think what you see a lot is there's a
lot of companies especially at wework
where you created custom operators so
it's not just using the vanilla
operator for postgres or for mysql or
for redshift there's a lot of
customization that happens
and really if someone wanted to create
their own
almost like marquez operator what do
they need to do that what are the apis
that we expose and what is the api
contract
and documentation that we we have to get
get people up and running
um and then yeah you know with this the
doc side of things
we do have a quick start guide but
there's a lot more that we could be
that could be done there and we're
excited uh to soon have a lot more
documentation around
one the airflow integration that we're
doing and also the
documentation for the marquez library
that's coming soon
um and the one the next phase is really
the
more of a mid medium term
is the spark integration so we're
starting to focus on that
um because that's a really key thing um
what we've what we've seen is air flows
is used for scheduling and then also
there's
with airflow you can kick off spark jobs
so it becomes really important for us to
start
capturing metadata from from spark
from spark applications
and now the other the other exciting
news is that um but
that i'd like to share is that marquez
did join the linux foundation
um more specifically lfai and that's
just a community of uh
you know open source projects that are
uh really looking to support
ml and ai am ai initiatives
uh so that was that was something that
was announced brief um not too long ago
and
we're excited to be part of part of that
part of the foundation
and yeah i think i think that's all i
got um
you know you there's uh there's some
docs that you can cut you could take a
look at
there's a quick start guide gives you an
overview a lot of what i discussed
already
but a little bit more detail into how we
do the versioning for jobs and data sets
and you could follow follow the project
on twitter
at marquez project and check out our
github repo at github.com
you